hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich habe mir den letzten paar tagen
einfach mal was neues ausgedacht und
zwar wird dieses neue konzept three
minutes heißen in diesem streaming ads
also halt einfach drei minuten werde ich
versuchen so viele fragen wie möglich zu
beantworten als es eigentlich nur ein
ganz normales fragen und antworten
ich habe ein paar tagen auf facebook
gepostet dass ihr mir unter diesen post
anhalt fragen stellen sollte da schaue
jetzt gleich mal rein und mal gucken wie
viele fragen die ich so in drei minuten
beantworten kann
also ich will auch gar nicht lange
lagern nicht mit sagen wir einfach mal
an für die die es noch nicht ganz
verstanden haben frau einfach an dein
jackie hat schon also wie man hier sieht
hier ist mein handy mit den ganzen
fragen und hier ist meine stoppuhr und
ich würd mal sagen
auf die plätze fertig los wie man sieht
es läuft frage nummer eins bist du
fußball fan also fußball an sich mag ich
aber auch lange selber fußball gespielt
aber falls du es jetzt so meinst dass
ich von haben speziell man spenden
das ist nicht wirklich so also schon
früher mal so richtig sofort erfolgt
wenn bayern oben dann war ich so bei
allen war eine andere mannschaft
irgendwas von denen er fällt aber halt
fußball an sich mag ich und so eine
spezielle bestimmte mannschaft als fan
oder die ich sehr gerne mag
aber jetzt eigentlich nicht frage noch
mal zwei was hältst du von youtube
netzwerken also netzwerke an sich finde
ich eigentlich schon eine gute sache
außer also komplett ganz aufs netzwerk
an ich war früher mit meinen alten
account in seinem komischen
amerikanische netzwerk habe ich halt nur
gemacht und haltbarer und so zu haben
wie das früher hat auf youtube apa und
jetzt bin ich mit diesem account in
medias kraft und zwischen diesen beiden
netzwerken
schon super welten würde ich mal sagen
also mehr kraft ist so auf den ersten
eindruck echt richtig heiß und dieses
komische amerikanische netzwerk da keine
ahnung also kommt aus netzwerk an aber
youtube netzwerk an sich finde ich
eigentlich eine richtig coole sache
nächste frage wirst du gerne mal schwul
also ich hab nichts gegen schwule aber
ich muss jetzt nicht unbedingt mal
schwul gewesen sein
kurze frage kurze antwort hast du schon
schule nein ich habe noch zwei wochen
ferien an die die scholl schule haben
tut mir leid für euch aber ihr hattet
ihr auch erfinden was würdest du machen
willst du für einen tag ein mädchen
also mir wird da eigentlich schon was
einfallen
aber das sage ich fest damit egal
gut ich gute antwort oder naja
vielleicht wisst ihr was ich meine
solltet ihr eigentlich hast du schon mal
einen fakten video gemacht wenn nicht
kannst du dann mal eins machen also hier
auf einem kanal habe ich vor drei wochen
also eingeladen
klickt ein warum einen kanal wenn ja so
nicht sehen wollt hier ist auch noch mal
wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt
jetzt auch noch mal verlinkt und ein
paar an jamie walker aber erst nach
diesem video wo ich jetzt so höre ich
jetzt nächste frage ich habe übrigens
noch einige zeit beschrieben geschrieben
geschrieben geschrieben wird als ich bin
mir geschrieben mitgeschrieben
geschrieben war geschiedene leute keine
ahnung alter was für eine frage wann
hast du geburtstag also ich hab am 16 07
neues ruhig geworden und ich werde also
dann in einem monat ungefähr 16
also ich bin zurzeit 15 würdest du die
bei meinen plänen von der stille oder in
einem großen dunklen raum sein was es
leid so der hintergedanke der frage ich
bin hier in meinem zimmer oder das
gefällt mir übel ich noch ein paar jahre
leben so 3 oder so und dann war's das
beim pizza oder döner ganz klar döner
also plötzlich auch gerne aber dünne
auch ich bei 19 erster rekord und
e-mails oder burger king ganz vermerke
sich jetzt gerne macbeth und zwar auch
aber möchte ich schon lieber spielst
oder kennst du minecraft klar kenne ich
minecraft ab
ich hab da irgendwie versteht keinen
sinn oder kann keinen sinn aus diesem
spiel raus interpretieren kannst du
einen überschlag machen klar wartet
sodann stellt die letzte fahrt noch ganz
kurz zeit
was unterscheidet dich von mir leicht zu
youtube jetzt bin ich zwar schon über
den drei minuten aber diese vielleicht
nehme ich jetzt einfach noch mit rein
keine ahnung auf youtube ist man noch
mal ein bisschen anders einmal auf
youtube
ich würde ich sagen dass man sich
vorstellt aber man ist schon ich finde
das kann man gar nicht vergleichen
bereit und youtube das eigentlich die
antwort darauf sage ich jetzt mal ja wir
sind jetzt bei drei minuten 30 anhalten
und noch eine wichtige frage zum schluss
die mir gestellt wurde abgesehen von
diesen streaming video erst mal bist du
auch auf der gamescom wo findet man
nicht dort postest du dann was also ich
bin dieses jahr leider nicht auf der
gamescom und auch nicht auf dem video
day deswegen rechnet da erst gar nicht
mit mir ich wäre gerne gekommen aber ist
jetzt irgendwie zu spät habe ich so
nicht auf die reihe bekommen habe in
letzter zeit auch nicht wirklich youtube
gemacht und das sollte ich noch mal
gesagt haben ich wünsche euch dort allen
viel spaß auf jeden fall und so das
war's mit dem ersten video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen oder
dieses neue stream ins konzept von mir
gefällt euch falls das der fall ist es
doch einfach mal einen daumen nach oben
da und schreibt so einfach unten in die
kommentare was ich verbessern kann
die ich das nächste mal einfach machen
soll ob ich so lassen soll keine ahnung
ich habe jetzt noch viele weitere fragen
ob ich die nächste stream im netz nehmen
und dann mal schauen oder ob ich noch
mal einen neuen preis mache oder ein
youtube-video zu früher als youtuber die
kommentare unter das video inhalten
können so das war's dann auch leider
schon wieder mit diesem fahren und
antworte video sage ich mal
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen falls sie
nicht verpassen wollt dann abonniert
doch einfach den kanal hier oben oder so
auf jeden fall kommt ihr hier und auch
zu meinem letzten video läuft jetzt um
die menschheit dass wir überhaupt das
wir verblöden und
einfach an oder hier zu meinem
vorletzten video fünf dinge die du
niemals zu mir sagen sollte
ich wünsche euch eine schöne ferien noch
der fall ist und wir haben heute
definitiv